So 널
So Leute, ich hab jetzt erst nur das Mikrofon angemacht, um euch erst mal ins Ohr zu husten.
Exzent.
Warte mal, ich muss mal kurz mein Mikro entwehren.
So, da sind wir.
Also, ähm, ich hab mich grad noch mal ne Stunde bewegt, Sachen gibt's sogar zweimal am Tag
heute.
Bewegung, was ist da los, bald ist nicht mehr Pippo Fett angesagt, ähm, weiß man was heute
neues vorgestellt wird, ja wahrscheinlich iOS 6, äh nicht iOS 6, wie komm ich auf iOS
6, iOS 14, äh, der Switch auf die ARM Architektur wahrscheinlich, neue, neues Mac OS vielleicht,
mal gucken.
Also, was ich sagen wollte, ich hatte echt Schiss das Event zu streamen, weil die sind
bei, ähm, auf Twitch sind sie dieses Jahr, aktuell seit, also eigentlich seit dieser
und letzter Woche, sind sie ja besonders scharf drauf was Copyright und sowas angeht.
Deswegen hab ich schon überlegt, ok soll ich das Stream sein lassen, oder soll ich
vielleicht streamen und nur labern und es nicht zeigen, allerdings war ich dann eben
mal auf Twitch und hab bei, äh, bei TryHacks gesehen auf Twitch, dass TryHacks einfach
mal ex, auf exzellente Art und Weise, jaja, ah, Twitch, geh fort, dass er auch äh, Apple
streamt, so und wenn TryHacks Apple streamt, dann kann er ja auch Apple streamen, was ist
das eigentlich für ein absolut nerviges Overlay, what the fuck, ich kann es nicht mal wegklicken,
geht das von alleine weg, ah, exzellent, was ist das für ein Bullshit, braucht doch kein
Mensch, oder, zumindest er streamt das auch und wenn TryHacks das streamen kann, dann
darf ich das auch streamen.
Wir müssen mal schauen wo es schneller ist, ob das Stream hier aktueller ist oder hier
aktueller, müssen wir mal schauen, ist euch mal aufgefallen, dass die ganzen Avatare
hier alle extrem hipster aussehen, das sieht einer mehr hipster aus als der andere, guckt
euch das an, fehlt bloß noch das auf dem Elektroroller kommen, das wärs jetzt noch
wenn Tim Cook auf dem Elektroroller reingefahren kommt.
Da ist er schon zu divers, da ist mir alles egal, ich find's bloß lustig, dass die alle
so extrem hipster aussehen in den Avataren, guckt mal, wer streamt den Kram hier gerade
noch, WWDC, äh, hallo, Twitch, es ergibt keinen Sinn, dass ich nach WWDC suche und
TryHacks nicht finde, TryHacks hat im Titel stehen, TryHacks hat im Titel stehen, WWDC,
warum finde ich WWDC nicht, wenn ich danach suche, weil die mich jebaiten, ok, jetzt findet
er's, ok, guckt mal Leute, so viele wie das hier streamen so, da kann ich das auch streamen,
sogar Dings hier streamt, ja, sogar er streamt hier, die streamen alle, dann streamen wir
das jetzt auch, letztes Mal war auch ok, aber letztes Jahr hat sich Twitch noch nicht so
eingekackt was Copyright anging, dieses seit zwei Wochen sind ja voll am Durchdrehen, by
the way, wir haben noch ungefähr eine halbe Stunde Zeit bis es losgeht, ich muss nebenbei
noch mal kurz was futtern, ja, du darfst nur vom Applegerät streamen, das haben sie ja
glücklicherweise abgehört, also, WWDC Predictions, gucken wir uns mal an was es da gibt, Reddit,
Reddit Predictions, weil wir wissen ja, dass Reddit prinzipiell most accurate ist bei
sowas, also Reddit macht da nichts vor, gefolgt von Twitter, natürlich nur getoppt durch
den Twitch Chat, jetzt wieder Bullshit Bingo, es gibt einen Excited Counter, es gibt einen
Excited Counter, aber ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher wie weit wir den einpletten, wir können
das in der OSX-VM anschauen, oh das ist Big Brain, das Problem ist nur, ich hab die OSX-VM
gelöscht, weil ich sie für nix gebrauchen kann und 60GB Plattenplatz auf der SSD weggenommen
hat, Siri OS, nämlich für Apple und Siri, was ist das Schwachsinn, gibt's da nicht
hier, Show Results, all Reddit Results, new Predictions, da richtig geschrieben, also irgendwie
gibt's da nix, hier Predictions, our Predictions, das haben wir mal schon gelesen, was da, was
die predigten, ich mein Apple wird sich natürlich wieder selbst feiern ohne Ende, wenn das einer
kann sich selbst feiern, dann ist es Apple, ich warte noch auf die Kamera mit, mit, auf
die iPhone Kamera mit, mit 4 Objektiven oder 5 Objektiven oder am besten noch unten und
oben ein Objektiv oder sowas, 360 Objektiv, forgets das hier, das da, bestes Addon für
Twitch, was es gibt, besser als Better Twitch TV, hat quasi alle Funktionen die Better Twitch
TV hat, bloß mehr und besser integriert, thefrangerz, thefrangerfaces, oh das sah er aber noch jung
aus, thefrangerfacesz, und morgen war ja, was heißt 2 Streams, heute morgen war ja nur ziemlich
kurzer Stream, oder wie man es auf hessisch sagen würde, ein kurzer Stream, war das, ein
Kotze Stream, war das heute morgen, ziemlich kurze Stream, hab gehört Cook will mit einem
Purzelbaum das Event eröffnen, ich kann mir nichts besseres vorstellen, nicht Kotze, Kotze,
ein kurze, kurz, Kotze, nicht Kotze, das TZ wird dann nicht betont, ein Kotze, warum binde
Twitch die nicht einfach offiziell ein, weil Twitch gerne Kontrolle über die Emotes hat
und gucken ob, gucken wollen ob die in ihr Monka Toss passen, und bei FFZ und Better Twitch
TV kann ja jeder fast alles einreichen, was kann man bei FFZ dagegen machen, dass nicht
alle Emotes angezeigt werden, du musst Better Twitch TV Emotes explizit aktivieren und du
musst Animated Gifts explizit animieren, ich bin aber auch ganz froh, dass Twitch da
nicht das sagen hat, stell euch vor Twitch hätte bei FFZ und Better Twitch TV Emotes
das sagen, dann würden manche Emotes nicht reinkommen, zum Beispiel würde das hier Twitch
garantiert nicht genehmigen, bei Twitch ist es ja auch gar nicht erlaubt die Gesichter,
es mag jetzt erstmal widersprüchlich klingen, aber es ist nicht erlaubt die Gesichter bekannt,
also existierender Personen zu nehmen, also du kannst jetzt nicht, ich könnte jetzt nicht
einfach einen Emote machen mit einem Bild von irgendjemandem bekannt drauf, das geht
nicht, darfst du nicht bei Twitch Emotes, dass es natürlich Emotes gibt mit Bildern
von Mitarbeitern von Twitch oder von Channel Besitzern, auf Twitch ist das was anderes,
da ist die rechte Situation aber geklärt, ich weiß nicht ob ihr das mitgekriegt habt
mit dem Lull Emote, ich mein ihr kennt alle das ursprüngliche Lull Emote, das war das
hier, auf Twitch ist es jetzt das hier und warum ist das so, weil TotalBiscuit nicht
alle Rechte hatte an seinem eigenen Face und wie kann das sein, warum hat TotalBiscuit
nicht die Rechte gehabt an seinem eigenen Gesicht, weil er nicht das Foto gemacht hat
sondern jemand anderes das Foto geschossen hatte und deswegen musste Twitch das Emote
nachmalen und konnte nicht das ursprüngliche Lull verwenden, so gestört ist es mittlerweile
mit Copyright schon, welches NAS war nochmal das Board mit onboard CPU was du für NAS empfiehlst,
kann ich nix, ich kann dir sagen was ich hab, das hier, wo ist es denn, das hier hab
ich, Chat ihr macht das Copypasta nicht richtig, das geht anders, die PokeV I'm safe, da fehlt
der Virgin Check davor, nichtmal richtig Copypaste kann der Chat, das ist echt schlimm, das hab
ich als aktuelles NAS Build, wobei ich halt nicht so wirklich empfehlen kann, es war halt
wirklich ultra low budget NAS was ich da gebaut hab, immer gespannt wo die frühe am Start
sind, hier oder hier oder hier oder bei TriHacks oder bei hier, ok er ist schon am Start hier,
er ist schon am Start, by the way ich kann mir seine Videos beim besten Willen nicht
angucken, ich find das so anstrengend ihm zuzuhören, jeder wie er mag ja aber ich find's
ultra anstrengend, was mich jetzt noch interessieren würde, wo ich noch ein bisschen Schiss habe
ist labern die alle nur oder zeigen die auch das Event, wenn die das Event zeigen, ich
guck mir das an wie das TriHacks macht, dann zeige ich auch das Event, moin Neko Rock,
der Odroid HC2 der ist nicht so gut, achso der HC2 ja das hab ich auch, das ist wenn
du so ein fixes und fertiges haben willst, das ist auch gut ja, wenn du keine 10G Performance
brauchst so nach dem Motto, dann ist das ok, ja ich hab das schon zu einem Apple Event
gemacht aber die sind ja dieses Jahr besonders pingelig was Copyright angeht, ich komm
mir voll ausgestoßen vor wenn ich die ganzen Apple Avatare mir angucke, die sehen alle
so hip aus, also ich wüsste mir da zumindest mal, entweder so richtig Anubis Bart wachsen
lassen, das ist auch ziemlich hipster, kennt ihr das, das ist so grad voll angesagt, so
Anubis Bart oder wenigstens ne Klatze oder so, Pepo Fett, das bin ich genau ich sitz
hier am Notebook, Leute ich bin dabei, ich spiegel mich im MacBook fuck, ich muss die
Emotes hier weg machen, weil ich wette mit euch, es gibt Leute die stören sich da dran,
dass ich die Emotes da drüber mache und dann sage ich mag keine Leute die so aussehen,
weil ich die Emotes da drüber mache, was an Anubis Bart sein, ich hab keine Ahnung
wie das heißt, so ein spitzer Bart halt, ihr wisst doch was ich mein, der so spitz ist,
ey kein Ziegen, so ne richtig lange Keule so, ok wir gucken mal, hipster Bart, was gibt's
denn da alles, ja sowas hier, sowas hier mein ich, das ist richtig hipster, so geht
das, exzellent, sowas müsste ich überwachsen lassen, dann wäre das wenigstens ok, ja bei
dem sieht das gut aus, der hat das auch ultra ordentlich geschnitten, ja da ist der auf
1mm genau, was sagt eigentlich TriHack Stream, oh 5 Minuten WWDC, was sagt es bei ihm, hatte
heise nicht auch nen Stream, heise WWDC, hatten die nicht auch nen Stream, ok Leute wenn die
restream mach ich das auch, ich seh das nicht ein, dass ich der einzige bin der sich da
dran hält, glaubst du der Odroid H2 Plus ist gut genug um ein Sophos Home drauf laufen
zu lassen, ich hab keine Ahnung was ein Sophos Home ist, also irgendeine Firewall mit Zusatzfunktionen
ja, aber ich hab keine Ahnung was das alles kann, was das macht, was das für Anforderungen
hat, legit keinen Plassen Schimmer, was kostet es denn überhaupt, wow Moment man braucht
nen Account um sich was zu installieren, ich finde bei FFZ wirklich nicht die Option für
Bella Twitch TV und Animate, ich zeigs dir, ich zeigs dir wo es ist, so gehen wir mal
hier in Chat, ah nee ich bin nicht angemeldet, oh ich glaub FFZ ist gerade kaputt kann das
sein, also FFZ, konnte man das nicht mal größer machen, gut will dir mal auch sein, du suchst
jetzt mal nach GIF, da ist es hier, Addons, Bella Twitch TV Emotes und dann sagste Enabled,
es kann übrigens sein, dass wenn du Bella Twitch TV Emotes nicht hast, dass du noch
nen zweites Addon für Bella Twitch TV Emotes installieren musst, aber ich glaube, ich glaube
das haben sie mittlerweile mit eingebunden, weil ich hab auch nur eine Sache installiert,
ich bilde mir ein, das haben sie mit eingebunden mittlerweile, vielleicht musst du das auch
im Infranker Faces Set machen, ja du brauchst zumindest dieses Menü hier und dann kannst
du die Animated GIFs einschalten oder wie die coolen Leute jetzt wieder sagen würden
GIF, wobei es nicht GIF heißt, sondern GIF, die Emotes bei ihm sind teilweise auch alle,
also okay die streamen alle, dann ist mir wurscht, dann streame ich ja auch jetzt, easy, 17 Minuten
gehts los, so Leute nebenbei esse ich mal kurz was, na, na warte mal ganz kurz, halbe
Minute, ich bekleide mich danach, ich bekleide mich danach, ich hole mal was zu trinken,
ich trinke nach unten, ich hole auch eine Z 문us mit Dabei stelle ich hier ein macro
So, und erstmal Klimaanlage anmachen, jetzt ist übel so warm.
Gestern habe ich übrigens voll verkackt mit der Klimaanlage.
Ich bin ins Bett gegangen, habe mir gedacht, ah busy warm ist es, lässt mal 10 Minuten
die Klimaanlage laufen und machs wieder aus.
Und was habe ich gemacht?
Klimaanlage, Klimaanlage angeschaltet und nicht gesehen, dass ich auf Heizen stehe.
Ich habe schon gedacht, irgendwie geht das Ding nicht an, was ist da los?
Bin ich mal aufs Klo gegangen und als ich wiedergekommen bin, war es, keine Ahnung,
gefühlt 28 Grad im Zimmer oder so.
So, und dann habe ich zum ersten Mal festgestellt, was passiert, wenn man die Klimaanlage von
Heizen auf Kühlen umschaltet.
Das verwirrt die Klimaanlage, da knackts nämlich.
Habe umgeschaltet und dann hat die Klimaanlage erstmal gemacht, habe ich auf Bonkers.
Was jetzt, habe ich erstmal ausgeschaltet, 5 Minuten gewartet und wieder eingeschaltet
und dann gings.
Dann hat es wieder runtergekühlt, exzellent.
Auf wieviel Grad stellst du es zum, äh die Gradanzahl ist das gleiche, 22 Grad hatte
ich eingestellt.
22 Grad, aber die Klimaanlage macht immer erstmal so 2-3 Minuten lang, dreht die immer
erstmal relativ hoch und dann regelt sie runter.
Wahrscheinlich muss die, wahrscheinlich kann die nicht lauwarm anfangen, sondern muss
erstmal das Heizding anschmeißen und kann das dann erst nachher regeln oder so.
Was hast du für eine Klimaanlage?
Ich äh, Moment, mit so Bischie, mit Bischie, äh Z, warte mal, Klima, Z, äh, ja, das
ist, ach du Scheiße, wie heißt denn das Ding, M, äh, Z, irgendwas mit Z, ah ja, ja, ja,
sowas hier.
Sowas hier habe ich, genau sowas hier, ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob es exakt dieses Modell
ist, aber genau diese Geschichte, ich hab außen an der Wand so ein Teil hängen, das
kann heizen und kühlen und innen hab ich im Arbeitszimmer so ein Ding mit Fernbedienung
und im Schlafzimmer ich so ein Ding mit Fernbedienung.
Einen Umfrage, Umfragevorschlag erhalten.
Äh, John hat ein DVD, das verstehe ich nicht, das ist mir zu big brainig, die brauchen
ordentlich Leistung, ja gut, dann kann ich alles haben.
Erstmal Hände waschen Leute, falls ihr gerade von draußen kommt.
Ah, jetzt habe ich den Witz verstanden, oder ist Paynes Champ?
Äh, also dass ich so ein Teil an der Wand hängen hab, juckt mich überhaupt gar nicht.
Ich frage mich ob die alle das Event zeigen, ob ich das Event zeigen darf, ich will wissen
was die hier alle machen.
Wie sieht das bei Heise aus?
Ah, Heise zeigt das ja auch in dem, wir werden es ja spätestens in 2-3 Minuten sehen wenn
es losgeht.
Oder spätestens wenn die Pre, wobei guck mal die haben hier auch eingeblendet.
Was kostet die Installation von so einer Klimaanlage?
Ich krieg es ehrlich gesagt nicht mehr zusammen was der Kram gekostet hat.
Ich glaube, ich glaube ich hab irgendwas um 2000 Euro bezahlt.
Könnte auch ein bisschen mehr gewesen sein, ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Was frisst so ein Ding an Leistung?
Äh, nachdem ich gerade unten meinen Stromzähler nicht laufen habe, kann ich es dir gerade
nicht sagen.
Also den Stromzähler den ich auslesen kann von hier oben, der ist gerade nicht angestöpselt.
Ich hab ja im Keller ein ESP32 hängen, der sowohl den ollen Drehzähler als auch den
oberen fürs obere Stockwerk ausliest, der ist gerade nicht an.
Le Stream, okay Leute, die re-streamen alle das Event, alle, die re-streamen echt alle,
warum sollte ich den Kram nicht auch re-streamen?
Mit 2000 Euro ist man gut dabei, es könnte auch ein bisschen teurer gewesen sein, aber
ich glaube, so um die 2000 Euro hat das gekostet.
Aber ich hab die Klimaanlage ja auch meistens nicht durchgängig laufen, ich mach das immer
so, wenn es mir zu warm wird, mach ich das Ding an, ähm, dann lass ich das meistens
20 Minuten laufen und wenn es mir dann anfängt zu ziehen, mach ich wieder aus und das hält
da ne Weile.
Also zumindest wenn es nicht so extrem warm ist, im Sommer, also wenn es richtig heiß
draußen ist, 36 Grad plus, mach ich es manchmal so, dass ich im Schlafzimmer, also auf ganz
kalt Stelle die Klimaanlage die Tür offen lass und die Klimaanlage volle Pulle abends
mal 2-3 Stunden laufen lass, weil dadurch wird das komplette Haus kühler, nicht kühl,
aber kühler.
Greta weint, das mag sein, aber das ist mir wurscht, ob die weint, solange ich nicht schwitzen
will, weine ich zumindest nicht.
Soll ich mal aufgefallen, wie wenig sich die Leute jetzt für Umweltsachen interessieren
auf einmal?
Davor, bevor Corona und Gedöns am Start war, war Umwelts Zeug, da ist der Weltuntergang
am Start gewesen und jetzt interessiert es keinen mehr.
Vor allem als wäre es jetzt weg, das ist noch genauso schlimm wie vorher.
Solaranlage kaufen, dann lohnt sich so eine Klimaanlage richtig, ja, da bin ich tatsächlich
gerade dabei.
Angel nein, da bin ich gerade dabei, ich hab in 2-3 Wochen kommt einer, ich weiß nicht
genau wann, ich glaub hier irgendwann kommt einer von der Stadtwerke und erklärt mir,
was es geiles gibt dafür.
Neun Minuten, ja, ja aktuell ist es ganz gut für die Umwelt, weil da vieles runtergefahren
ist, aber danach wird es eher schlechter.
Bitte mit Speicher, klar, Klimaanlage ohne Batterie oder ohne Akku ist doof, weil das
ist ja keine Batterie mit Akku, das ist bescheuert, das lohnt sich nicht.
Bekommt man noch Geld fürs Einspreisen?
Ja, aber ich weiß nicht, wie weit sich das noch lohnt.
Sind wir hier Fanboys oder Hater?
Das kann sich jeder selbst überlegen.
Naja, ist aber witzig, ne?
Dies ist vorher Umweltgeschichten voll angesagt, kam Corona, interessiert kein Mensch mehr.
Vor allem als ist es in irgendeiner Art und Weise besser geworden, auf lange Sicht.
Aber ich glaube, dass ein bisschen, ein bisschen eine Sache spielt da mit rein, warum es jetzt
glaube ich weniger Leute interessiert, weil viele festgestellt haben, oh fuck, so reich
sind wir gar nicht, weil nach fünf Wochen Corona haben wir alle kein Geld mehr.
Ob das dann so eine gute Idee ist, dass wir komplett die Umwelt im Alleingang retten?
Aber ich bin nach wie vor der Meinung, dass das eines der wichtigsten Themen ist, worum
sich die gesamte Menschheit kümmern muss.
Ich, ich bin ja schon froh, ich bin, ich bin ja schon froh, dass es kaum noch welche gibt,
die sagen, äh, Klimawandel oder, oder generell Klimaproblematik existiert nicht.
Das war vor ein paar Jahren noch anders, das war vor ein paar Jahren noch anders, da gab
es noch genug, die gesagt haben, ne, ne, das ist alles ausgedacht.
Mittlerweile stellt sich ja nur, nur eher die Frage, also, dass es Probleme gibt, bestreitet
kaum noch einer.
Heute, aktuell, ist ja eher die Problematik, wo sich so ein bisschen der, der Streit dran
äh, entzündet, ob da jetzt, äh, der Mensch viel Einfluss drauf hat oder nicht.
Oh, also das ist ja gerade so die, die Sache.
Und das ist auch wieder ein, äh, auch wieder ein Punkt, wo ich mich auch permanent drüber
aufregen könnte, wenn da diskutiert wird.
Ähm, auch wenn ich persönlich der Meinung bin, dass es relativ, nämlich, also, dass
die Indizien sehr stark dafür sprechen, dass wir was dafür können, mit unserem Lebensdien
der letzten 40, 50 Jahre angefangen, ähm, finde ich trotzdem wichtig, dass man sich
auch mal kritische Punkte anhört, wo Leute sagen, okay, ha, vielleicht gibt's da noch
ein paar andere Aspekte, aber das geht ja gerade nicht, ja.
Wenn irgendjemand öffentlich sich hinstellt und sagt, ja, äh, Klimawandel, ich bin der
Meinung, äh, der Mensch kann da gar nix, bla, bla, bla, aus diesen und diesen Punkten, der
wird ja medial, äh, g-gesteinigter.
Das, das sorgt nicht dafür, dass Leute, die der Sache eh kritisch gegenüberstehen, irgendwie
ihre Meinung ändern, ja, aber trotzdem, ich find's gut, wenn man die Leute mal zur Sprache
kommen lässt, sollen sie sich doch mal auslassen, ist doch okay, ich mein, ups, ich will nicht
nach I suchen, wer weiß, was ich da finde, ich mein, es gibt immer wieder Berichte so
nach dem Motto, ähm, sogar, sogar, ähm, Nobelpreisträger hätten Kritik am menschgemachten Klimawandel,
hey, sollen sie doch, lasst sie doch einfach mal ihre Punkte vorbringen, wo ist das Problem?
Wie gesagt, ich bin persönlich der Meinung, es liegt total auf der Hand, dass wir dran
schuld sind, ähm, aber warum lässt sich nicht mal auch andere Standpunkte anhören, da stirbt
noch keiner von.
Aber zum Glück, zum Glück sind wir mittlerweile, es hat sich in den letzten Jahren schon ein
bisschen was getan, sind wir mittlerweile alle auf dem Stand, ähm, dass zumindest keiner
mehr sagt, gibt es gar nichts, das ist ja schon mal gut, weil vor ein paar Jahren gab's
noch genug Leute, die gesagt haben, gibt es gar nicht, ja, äh, PlayerRed1 bis zu einem
gewissen Grad, aktuell ist es so, dass du, ähm, wenn, wenn du irgendwas nur halbwegs
als Mainstream bezeichnen kannst, dort definitiv keiner der Kritiker zu Wort kommt, das find
ich schlecht, und wenn da einer zu Wort kommt, wird er mit medial komplett fertig gemacht
oder in irgendwelchen Diskussionsrunden, gnadenlos niedergeredet, sogar vom Moderator selbst.
Ähm, das find ich in allen Bereichen übrigens nicht gut, so, jetzt müssen wir mal gucken,
ob's hier gleich losgeht, wie sieht's bei TriHacks aus, guckt sich eine komische Fitness-App
an, wie sieht's hier aus, wie sieht's hier aus, ich will wissen, ob die restreamen oder
nicht, restreamen, alter, wenn die nicht restreamen, restream ich auch nicht, ich will wissen, ob
die restreamen, also wenn das, Leute, ich sag euch, wenn das nicht erlaubt ist, wenn
das restreamen nicht erlaubt ist, dann laber ich nur oder müsst ihr den Stream selbst
aufmachen, okay, mal fort, was ist das hier, ich hab schon mal ein Apple Event restreamt,
ich weiß, ich weiß, aber dieses Jahr sind sie, was Copyright angeht, besonders scharf,
ja, heise, heise restreamt, ja, ach, ich dachte es ist ein Counter, das ist ein Herzrate, ich,
ich guck, was die anderen machen, ey, wenn die anderen streams auf Twitch, die anderen
großen streams, also restream, restream ich das auch, wäre das nicht gut für Apple, wenn
du restreamst, klar, überall, wo sie Aufmerksamkeit bekommen, wo sie sonst keine bekommen würden,
wäre nice, was macht heise so, ah ja ja, wen haben sie da dabei, excellent, oh, oh, ich
schau was Leute, äh, äh, wo kommt der Sound her, ah, ihr habt gar keinen Sound, der Sound
kommt bei mir vom zweiten Browser Tab, lull, was wird denn heute vorgestellt, ich weiß
es nicht so genau, okay Leute, ich guck, wie die anderen das machen, wenn die auch nicht
restreamen, dann laber ich auch nur, ah, ne, okay, die restreamen, okay, YOLO, die haben
2000 Zuschauer, wenn das nicht erlaubt ist, dann weiß ich auch nicht, Gag W, der restreamt
auch, okay, ne, ne, ne, dann restream ich auch, dann laber ich nur, dann restream ich auch,
Chris Downhenge, neuen Monat, excellent, heise ist auch dabei, heise ist auch dabei, die Twitch-Suche
ist mega fail, Alter, warum findet man das nicht, lustig eigentlich, echt fail, dass
man das nicht findet, okay, gleich gehts los, weil eben lag das Stream, die zeigen das auch,
warum läuft das hier übrigens nicht weiter, so, schauen wir mal, was da rauskommt, wir
müssen gleich die Lautstärke, oh, Leute, es geht aus, ne, she baited, Tri-Extremt auch,
gut, dann, Apple stellt flache Erde vor, Eye-Earth, ah, das ist vorher, jetzt gehts
los, okay, die restreamen das alle, da mach ich das jetzt auch, who cares, oh, die Bitrate
ist übelstreudig schlecht, Alter, Leute, soll ich die Bitrate vom Stream ein bisschen
hoch machen, oder passt das so, da isser, a cuppa brite man himself, das ist huge ass
SYNC, mit hilf, das ist ass SYNC as fuck, okay, excellent,
oh, jetzt kommt das Thema hier auch schon,
aber dass das gleich am Intro kommt, noch ein bisschen lauter, oder passt,
gibt's jetzt schwarze iPhones,
ah,
Achtung, das ist ein Virus, das die täglichen Leben der Billionen von Leuten beeinflusst.
Wir wollen die Menschen überall bedenken.
V.a. unsere Krankenhäuser, die sich für die Menschen in der
Bedarf beteiligt haben. Wir haben auch gesehen, wie großartig unsere Produkte sind.
Die Menschen sind mehr als immer daran beteiligt, sich mit Familie und Freunden zu befinden,
um ihre Arbeit zu machen, um ihre Kreativität zu verbreiten, um sich zu enttäuschen,
und auch um andere zu enttäuschen. Heute ist der Welt auf uns alle zählen
und auf die Produkte und Erfahrungen, die wir kreieren, um vorwärts zu gehen.
Denn während der Geschichte haben großartige Herausforderungen getroffen mit großartiger Kreativität
und wichtigen Wettbewerben. Deswegen sind wir so begegnet...
Oh, begegnet!
This is going to be truly a unique week, delivered unlike any that we've done before.
There will be more than a hundred engineering-led video sessions,
one-on-one consultations with Apple engineers, developer forums, and so much more,
delivered to you from different locations right here at Apple Park.
This year, conference will be available to our entire community of 23 million developers,
as well as anyone who is interested for free.
Presenting the conference in this way allows us to be more inclusive than ever.
Perhaps this will inspire the next generation of developers.
So even though we can't be together in person, in some ways we're going to be more together than ever.
Today, we're going to push each of our platforms forward in some exciting and breakthrough ways.
Zwei. Zwei. Excited. Zwei.
Excellent. Craig am Start.
Good morning. Great to have you here.
As you can see, we've got a lot to cover.
So let's get started with iOS.
Together with iPhone, iOS is central to how we navigate our lives and stay connected.
And now we're making it even more powerful and easier to use.
Our new release is iOS 14.
This year, we spent time rethinking some of the most iconic elements of the experience on iPhone.
Now it all started here with a carefully considered home screen that has truly stood the test of time.
Of course, over the years, we kept the fundamentals largely the same, but carefully added features like folders for organizing your apps,
and personalized experiences powered by on-device intelligence that serve up just the right thing at just the right moment.
It's hard to imagine an iPhone without these features now.
Well, that brings us to this year.
We're doing more on our iPhones today than ever before.
So we've rethought some of the core elements of iOS to reflect this.
Let me give you a quick peek.
Eine Uhr.
What is happening?
Sodoku.
Ah, Desktop widgets.
Let's dig in, starting with the home screen.
Today's home screen works great, but as we get more and more apps, we can end up with this.
Lots and lots of pages.
Ja, so sieht's bei mir auch aus.
Wouldn't it be great if there were a way to organize all of those apps without doing a thing?
Well, this year we're doing just that with something called the App Library.
AI.
Pass auf, Leute.
Da sagt gleich noch Machine Learning.
Machine Learning gestürzt.
Das lassen die sich nicht nehmen.
AI-Folders.
Moment, das heißt offiziell Jiggle Mode?
Ah, AI.
Da ist es, AI, Leute.
Ist das Fortnite?
Hat der Fortnite installiert?
Guck mal unten rechts, ist das Fortnite?
Aha.
Okay.
Also Apple Watch geht voll an mir vorbei.
Ich meine, dass man den Widget resizen kann, ist jetzt ja nur wirklich keine große Errungenschaft.
Ah, das ist gut, das ist gut.
Das ist gut.
Das finde ich gut.
So smart.
AI-controlled Smart Stack.
Exzellent.
Ich hoffe, man kann das Workflow automatisieren.
Geht das nicht jetzt schon?
Das geht, das geht jetzt schon.
Ach, auf dem iPhone.
Ah.
Exzellent.
Okay, das ist gut.
Das ist gut.
Man kann es ein- und ausplätten.
Oh, bei YouTube wird es nicht gehen.
YouTube kannst du klicken.
YouTube schaltet den Grad explizit ab.
Premium, Alter, YouTube Premium.
Ich glaube, es geht los.
Ich habe Siri aber aus.
Action Costa.